No, I, well, I followed you like when you were at your peak.
So, oh, ow.
Ow.
Okay, you know what?
You can just, you can just take the attitude.
Ow.
I guess I'm washed up, chat.
I mean, how many years ago was, I guess I'm washed.
Washed up.
I mean, it was one class.
click okay okay okay okay how about this how about this i'll
follow you back yeah i'll follow you back yeah all of you
shut up my friend fuzzy's box all right all right okay
follow me first no no no no no this is that no no no no no
no follow me first how would i know i already did my one
click hey hey hey hey because that that that that that was
besides the point okay that's You're nervous?
You're gonna be nervous.
See that?
Like, that's besides the point of the game.
Hey, all right.
How about you follow me first and I'll give you your shout
out.
It's just that easy.
Because that's the issue.
So here, here's the issue.
Yeah.
Whether Fuzzy gets a shout out or not, it doesn't benefit me
at all.
Yeah, but you clearly, you clearly want to do this for your
chatter.
You clearly, because it's day two and you're still on about
this Fuzzy guy.
guy is that you could have moved on after day one yeah but i
don't think he can move on that's the issue yeah so if you
really like your chatter if you really appreciate them
follow me on twitter right now fuzzy fuzzy are you my chat
still how much how much or fuzzy ditch that guy and come to
my chat i'll appreciate you if you come to my chat i'll give
you a shout out and i won't even Yeah, no, he just said, I'm
in Doki's chat right now.
Oh, shit, yeah, and your guy was like, I'm the Sonic
chatter, too.
Oh, man, your fans coming to me now.
I don't need that follow.
I got Fuzzy already.
Take him.
You don't need him?
All right.
That's why you got ninth place on Comma Breaker, Fuzzy.
Other viewers in Sonic Chat, I would appreciate you.
I would follow somebody to give you that shout out, but
apparently Sonic doesn't care.
Sonic doesn't care at all.
It's literally one click.
That's right.
The offer's gonna go.
All right, if you don't do that follow, you'll never get
that shout out or Sonic or Fuzzy back.
Fuzzy, you're gonna have to beg me for this.
You're gonna have to beg me for this because there's no
incentive.
The fact that you can't even do one click says a lot.
Fuzzy, I didn't mean it.
I'm sorry.
But yeah, I'm joking.
Okay.
Fuzzy, you don't have to beg in my chat.
Listen, listen, Doki.
I could tell we're both stubborn people.
So how about this?
How about this?
I don't follow you.
Yeah.
But?
You shut up Fuzzy anyway.
All right, goodbye.
Fuzzy's my chatter now.
You know what I take him.
You know what I'm saying?
You know what I could save your life and you know We can
both you know survive and thrive together.
Okay.
I'm clicking the eject button I'm gonna watch you.
I'm gonna watch you perish.
Okay.
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be all I'm saying is that I have the
support of my fans I'm gonna be clasping my hands together.
I guess you fall to your demise.
Feels like you're projecting Sonic.
Maybe I am, okay?
Is that such a bad thing?
Oh shit, Fuzzy!
Thanks for the sub, Fuzzy!
Oh my god!
Fuzzy, you're not a real one.
You're not the real one.
You won't do stuff for your homies.
I'm not real at all.
all right hey guys so like yeah like that came out of
nowhere i was literally eating and then and then sonic just
came over it was like hey and i was like hey while i was
trying to eat i was really trying to speed around my fucking
lunch during the waiting room all right we have my half
finished fucking meal in front of me um the content came to
me yeah sonic fox jumpscare i was like oh shit okay i guess
it's content time hello everybody welcome to day two you
know like okay you know what's funny after day one i was
like oh my gosh why did i i was like oh my god i could have
been eliminated and just chilled and like I told my friends
and my friends were like Bro, you could have like Why did
you do this to yourself?
I was like But I just wanted to win I just wanted to survive
And then yeah And then my friends were like you're so stupid
So I guess I'll be here for day two I'm pretty sure I'm
gonna get eliminated On day two though my gosh but my
exposure my free exposure chat for the 1k bro 1k i need to
survive for like two more days guys like this lobby is like
90 percent minecrafters there is no way any of us are good
any of the normies out here that don't play minecraft are
gonna survive to date to date 3 and 4 my god anyway uh so
yeah welcome to day two of the minecraft twitch rivals the
haunted house uh i think the the next this game this game
that we're gonna be doing is like we're supposed to like
dodge the monsters or something and like run run from them
and avoid them so uh that's basically it i don't know if the
let me know the cinematics by the way there's no emo mode
today um yeah Apparently, the monsters are going to be
chasing us.
Like, we have to cross some zones.
And then we have to...
We have to cross some zones and...
Get to the monsters.
And, like, avoid the monsters and stuff to the safe zone.
What else do I want to say?
Oh, yeah.
There's no emote mode this time.
Because there's nothing to Ghost at the moment.
So there's no emote mode.
So you guys can, like, backseat me for...
You know, if there was...
If there was no emote mode in the very first game, I would
have known about the tech.
You guys would have yelled at me about this, the jump tech,
guys.
You guys would have yelled at me about this.
Anyway, is Fuzzy still in my chat, Fuzzy?
Oh, wait, I hear gloomy.
Gumi!
Hi!
Donkey, I was looking for you earlier, and I found you, but
you were AFK.
Wait, oh, yeah, yeah, I was eating.
Wait, why is there a ghost here?
What's she doing here?
Donkey, you can rest people in the next game.
Oh, okay, okay, we gotta stick together.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, it's like Apex Legends.
Okay, okay, okay, well, you gotta stick together.
Hear my voice.
Well.
Yeah.
Don't, I'll be screaming.
Don't worry if I die.
I'm gonna stick with Ant Frost, and you can stick with me
with Ant Frost.
Oh, okay, okay, and then Ant Frost will carry both of us.
Yeah.
Yeah?
Because he's so strong.
Yeah, you're so, oh my god, Ant Frost, have you been working
out?
Ant Frost, whoa!
Whoa!
Oh my god Has anyone ever told you that you might be the
best Minecraft player in the server?
Yes, thank you Charlie
It's okay as long as like as long as we I think it only
matters if you're in the finals You've been going around the
world so either.
I think they just added that for fun.
Where the fuck is it?
Oh, there she is.
I think you are.
I think you're gonna make it.
You're gonna be fine.
I was like, what?
Are we still following the ghost?
Okay.
Guys, I don't think the ghost leads anywhere, guys.
Oh my god, there's so many people.
There's so many people.
I'm getting overwhelmed.
Oh my god, please, please.
Okay, I'm gonna find a corner to hide.
There's too many voices.
voices do you hear all those voices there's too many voices
what do they say all right i'm gonna eat my lunch by the way
i was speed running uh the con convention crowd no man oh my
god but yeah i can't believe it the the uh what's the word
my will to win overpowered my overpowered my rational I was
just like You know I was like Oh my god I made it to the
next day And then like 30 minutes later The realization came
in I was like Oh my god I made it to the next day
Hey What is that Where's your allies I think I got this one
Yeah Oh you need an ally Don't you Erab I apparently know
We're three more Yeah Are you desperate now?
I mean, we were both friends in Mendoza, so I think it's...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You wanted to be allied with a V-Tuber?
Is that where you're at in your life now?
I have nothing against V-Tubers.
Yeah, I have nothing against V-Tubers?
Is that what your chat's saying, too?
Is that what your chat is not representing?
me oh he doesn't represent you oh so you're saying your chat
chat's liars then my chat is not reflecting oh i see i see
well you know like this game you can rest people right the
next game yeah so uh i got you you got me yeah yeah right
i know you Rob's desperate for allies.
I guess all his allies are dead.
Oh, my stamina's on cooldown?
Okay, we got five.
Oh, Gumi.
Gumi's here.
Alright.
Here you go.
Yeah, if all his allies died, did not make it.
Alright.
Yeah, we have stamina now.
Yeah, apparently like, oh my gosh, my fucking food.
I can't even eat my food!
God damn it!
Alright.
We have voice chat reconnecting in three minutes.
Oh, no, I lost her.
I looked away to put my food away
All right.
Yeah, I know E-Rob's desperate now
He needs he needs people Wait, I lost her guys, where did
gumi go?
Look, I will carry E-Rob gumi will carry me and then and
Frost will carry a gumi.
We'll have like a chain We'll have a chain of people helping
Where the fuck did Gumi go?
Oh guys guys it's time to find where's Gumi our favorite
game We're oh there there she is nice.
Okay, all right the chain will start the circle All right,
so like apparently you can res people and All we need to do
is make sure we don't fucking die Or if we do die that That
we're close to our allies.
Okay.
Let's see.
Let me...
I feel like I should adjust the volume a little bit.
I'm going to put it at 90 because some of the volume is so
fucking loud sometimes.
But also, like...
Let me double check if...
Uh...
I'm going to bring up the game volume.
Okay.
My sound guy says bring up the game volume.
Wait, there's like more stuff now.
I guess I'll bring up the music.
and the environment.
Okay.
I don't know if that's better.
Alright, let's go.
So, for all the new viewers here, I usually stream on the
YouTube, so please check me out over there.
I do like the Twitch events.
The Twitch events I stream on Twitch because, you know, it
makes sense.
Twitch invite.
Whoa!
okay the voices came back chat oh sorry i misread my sound
guy he said bring it down i brought it back up there you go
all right the voices came back i got him we'll unmute when
the voices start slowing down we'll fix that later there's
just way too many too many people are still alive too many
people are still alive for this to work okay
oh my god took my meds and the voices are still coming
oh my god this is purgatory we will we will re-enable it
when the gate round starts I don't think I don't think I can
deal with the voices at the moment all right some way the
voices would guys I forgot to take my meds we know I took my
meds guys guys it's working the meds are working the voices
stopped oh my god
I told you.
Medicine works.
Oh, God.
Eerobb came back.
Don't worry.
I'll make sure I'll keep taking my meds.
Alright.
We're gonna have to we're gonna have to work together, guys.
This is a teamwork.
Eerobb found us.
We're gonna have to work.
Oh!
Monsters and pray
like this hello again the house of nightmare commends you
for surviving the conjures first two tests it is now time to
resume your challenge nightmares you will find yourselves in
the basement in the basement many of our ferocious monsters
and ghouls you may escape via any elevator at the far end of
the complex But they can hold only 100 of you.
We have to get to there.
To get to the elevators, you must proceed through two safe
zones.
Wait, that means eight people are going to get eliminated.
That protect you from the monsters.
Wait, what protects me?
The third and final safe zone is the elevator.
Move quickly, because the last few people to reach the safe
zone will not survive this nightmare.
Oh, shit.
In total, 10 of you will surrender yourself to the house
forever.
Guys, that's going to be me.
Along the way, monsters will attempt to attack you.
Wait, weapons?
You will be injured and unable to move at a normal speed.
Oh, so I have to make sure I don't...
If they are feeling...
There's parkour!
Other players can heal you by crouching next to you,
speeding up your recovery.
Oh, no, there's parkour.
But this is not a time to rely on others.
Because it's everyone who themselves...
Oh, no.
Oh, no, not platforming.
of you will have a stamina meter it will decrease as you
sprint and if it hits zero you will lose the ability to
sprint for three it was a good run guys it was guys it was a
good run now we have platform do your best to arrive safe
zone as quickly as possible it was a good run if the gate
the parkour is not that yeah okay for a normal person guys i
already have the vtuber debuff i don't know what you want
from me oh yeah guys i literally learned the jump tech oh my
god there's kachau i learned the jump tech like after the
game was over
see where is okay we need a fine wait where's goomy where's
goomy where is she i need her to rest me when i get hit i
need her to rest me i need to be on her backpack where's the
backpack where's that that's not very helpful guys that is i
don't know where oh there there's goomy That's her.
Wait, is that her?
Is that, yeah!
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We all stick together, yes?
Don't worry.
We stick together.
You save me.
Of course.
Wait, who's our group?
Who else do we get?
People that are coming over here.
We're meeting here.
Whoever's here is in our group.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, we're all gonna help each other out, right?
Warren, come here.
You wanna join our group?
Alright, guys.
Who's in this group?
Like the cool people.
Oh, my friends.
No, you guys want to stop.
Oh, that's tough.
That's tough.
This is it?
This is everyone?
Well, except for this guy.
This guy's not our friend.
That's crazy.
Except for that one guy over there.
He's so many friends.
I wish I had this.
I wish he too, man.
I don't care.
I don't care who.
We need to get everybody through this.
Yeah, totally me too.
healing i'm saving everybody bad i think we need to stay
near the beginning but don't stay too close to the beginning
so you want to like yeah like the front yeah let the people
in the front kind of act like me chill yeah they're all
gonna be like crying save us save me save us they cried out
save Okay, buddy, if you're saved, Gumi!
Wait, where's Ad?
I thought Ad was supposed to help us!
I'll miss you, Gumi!
Oh, okay, okay, I just thought Ad was gonna betray us there.
No, he would never.
I know where he is.
Yeah, where?
I'll keep it a secret.
Me and my child will keep it a secret.
2279.
Is he good?
Acacia Street.
Oh.
Okay.
I have to figure out the last.
Oh, no.
How am I supposed to win if we don't know his address?
Oh my god, two minutes.
Has it been eight minutes already?
Wait, really?
Damn.
All right.
Gumi, you wouldn't let me die, right?
We'll advance to day three together, right?
We'll get to you.
All I'm saying, Gumi, is for the fourth game.
If we combine our chat IQs together to do the puzzle, we
might be able to beat one puzzle We might be able to solve
one puzzle together Did you hear the lyrics?
Okay, let's go look for our friends Oh my god, everybody's
talking I found one Alright, wait, bad boy Halo is gonna
help us Oh, is that the group?
Yeah, but it's like bobbing like crazy out of my chest cross
you abandoned us i was scared you're gonna make sure we live
right at we gotta stick together okay yeah that was his
stutter like to get to the other side uh tunnel too he wants
to wait to leave a little huh oh i don't know about that
either he said he wants to use people as meat shields but i
think the monsters reset so yeah maybe maybe they're saying
that so that they he's gonna make us slow down and he's
gonna me in the front okay why don't we all leave on the
right hand side what do we all leave the right hand side of
the game yeah yeah yeah i like that that's a good idea
that's it you got it you can heal each other okay yep one
more minute one more minute exactly oh my god there's no way
to Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're like a pack of two for one.
A two for one deal.
Oh my god, there's so many people.
I'm using the stamina thing.
Are you ready?
I'm sorry.
Okay, I'm coming over here.
Wait, you can...
Like, hey W and then jump and like go over W and just like
move like that.
What?
Just like hit W and then jump and then like like go over W
and then sort of like jump along like this.
I understand what you mean.
I'm confused.
Okay, let's go.
Are we sprinting off this guy?
Oh, God.
Oh!
Here we go.
Get open.
The last one!
Yeah!
Where?
Where's my teeth?
No, I'm not music.
Guys, turn off the music, please.
It's so annoying.
Where's my team?
I don't know where my team is!
Sashi behind you.
Is that my team?
Yeah, we tried to, we tried to, we tried to.
Oh!
One guy fell.
Sashi.
I can't see shit!
I'm stuck!
I don't know where to go!
I can't see anything.
There's too many people.
Guys, am I doing anything?
I don't think I'm gonna get up here.
Okay.
I don't know where to go from here.
This is stressful.
Guys, it's over.
Guys, it's over, guys.
Guys.
It's so over.
I can't see.
Are you in a five right now or what are you doing?
Yeah, I'm in a five right now.
What's going on?
Guys, I can't see anyone.
Please get out of my face.
Oh, I'm trying to open his mouth.
Oh, wait, it's in front of me.
Jesus.
Okay, okay, guys.
I don't see you, but I think you're near me.
I see you.
I see steps.
No, just keep communicating with me.
Just so I can hear you.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh dude, you go under, you go under.
Where, where is anything?
I'm so, I'm so, I'm so confused.
Bottom, bottom unite.
I'm so, I'm so confused.
Oh, he's dead, he's dead!
I saw somebody die!
Oh my god, oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh, F5, you're right.
Wait, no, I can't because I don't know where to look at.
Oh my god, he's a dead guy!
Okay, this is fine!
Oh, there's so many dead people!
That's okay.
If I don't look behind me...
If I don't look behind me, everything will be fine.
Okay.
We're recharging.
Okay, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
I'm not gonna make it.
I'm gonna...
Okay, we're fine.
I hate this!
There's no way.
There's no way we're at the bottom.
Why are you telling me?
I'm sprinting.
Why are you guys?
Okay.
Oh my god, the first save zone.
We made it.
Oh,
that's the save zone.
Okay.
I didn't like that sound.
That sound was a little scary.
It was a little sus.
Oh, we're all in the same zone, so we all have to wait!
We all have to wait!
I think I got something out of my way!
Oh my god, nice!
We made it, like, barely!
We live!
We did it, we all live!
Okay.
Alright, we made it.
We made it.
We live!
I've been like really fucked up, but we didn't.
Oh god, thank you.
Oh god, I feel it.
oh everything is nice and quiet now we took our beds oh
thank god we took our beds
oh my god the voice is so good okay i did it i couldn't see
what was going on i have to f5
Yeah, that was fucked up.
I didn't remember that that first that first obstacle with
the trees that shit was crazy I don't even know how we got
there.
I think we got TP.
Oh my god E-Rob you made it Yeah, yeah, were you like were
you were you like 107th or something?
We did it guys.
We barely made it.
Oh my god.
It was me and you next to each other and I was like, I don't
know what we're gonna be.
We're sad for us.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
I took my meds.
That's okay.
Oh my god.
silence the voices are god oh thank god thank god oh my god
guys remember to take your meds or you're gonna have to
listen to that the whole time oh remember to take your meds
guys take your meds all right we have two more checkpoints i
i think we can make it we weren't in the back of the pack We
weren't... I think the moment I get hit by the monster, I'm
fucked.
I think that's really it.
The moment the monster fucking touches me, like, it's over.
Like, it's so over.
We just shouldn't let the monsters touch me.
And we should be good.
Oh, I feel like...
Yeah, there's no...
I feel like people don't revive.
Because, like, it's just so chaotic.
There's no way.
It's just so chaotic.
Oh, yeah, the parkour is going to be crazy.
The people who don't have the F5 is going to get fucked
over.
Because I could not see.
I could not see in first person at all.
Everyone's just running.
Remember to conserve your stamina.
Yeah, I need to remember to do that too.
Oh, wait, it's time.
We gotta get there.
It's okay.
We have peace and quiet.
I can't wait for more people.
I feel like we should be eliminating more people.
It's just...
108 is still too many.
People it's still too many
We need to get rid of some Yeah, this was not meant for this
many people I feel like maybe like have people each have
their own a parkour area Like maybe divided by 30 and then
we have like 30 of these like and then we have like multiple
multiple parkour areas and have 30 people in each I feel
like that would have been better.
It's just, yeah, multiple lobbies.
This is just too much.
This actually is too much.
I mean, I cannot, I can't even see where I am right now.
Like, guys, I don't know if I should play an F5.
I can't see where my body is.
Where am I?
I'm like in the pot.
I've been like in the heart.
Shit, the game almost crashed.
I'm like in the fucking club.
Oh Oh, where am I?
Guys, guys, I'm not gonna I don't guys.
I think this was a mistake guys Guys, this seems to be a
mistake now
oh no yes i think it's over yes i think it's over yes i'm
doing worse oh no oh no oh no i'm doing worse guys oh no oh
no this is bad okay we gotta do this i'm actually doing
worse now we got an f5 everybody i can't see i actually
couldn't see guys oh my god okay don't worry it's not over
yet we just gotta have to make it to the second checkpoint
everybody the moment we make it to the second checkpoint
will be okay
was definitely a mistake whoever said f5 that was a mistake
now we're fucked a little now now we're a little fucked guys
okay oh i can't i don't know how to like uh make it so that
guys how do you make it so i don't use my stamina
accidentally because because like it won't let me cancel it
i feel like i feel like i can't cancel it Oh, I got the one
of the got some no, no, no, oh no wait, do we have to do
this again?
Oh, I do.
No, my stamina.
Okay.
All right.
We're okay.
No, we're not okay.
Okay.
Slow and steady.
Slow and steady, dokey.
It's parkour!
There's people worse than you at parkour!
No.
Oh god.
There's people back there that's worse than you at this.
It'll be fine.
Oh my god.
There's people that are so cocky when it comes to parkour!
Okay, nice.
You got this.
Do I?
Oh no.
Oh my god.
My stamina.
Okay.
Oh there he is.
Oh god.
Oh, I'm so fucked.
I'm so fucked.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no.
Oh, behind me!
Is he behind me?
I don't want to look!
Oh, God.
Fuck.
Oh, that's scary.
That was so scary.
Oh, we're okay.
We're okay.
Oh my god, I just saw somebody died in front of me.
Oh.
Shit.
Oh god.
Like, it's so scary because, like...
Oh, my hands are shaking.
I hate parkour.
Oh, guys, this is so bad because my hands are actually
shaking.
Oh god.
Oh, okay.
We gotta recharge our stamina.
Oh, God.
Oh, my hands are shaking so much!
Woo!
I have to...
I'm so nervous, so I have to, like, do it one by one.
Because I'm so nervous.
because my hands are shaking so much
parkour makes me so nervous okay everything is okay oh oh
okay oh god oh god i thought i couldn't see i couldn't see
right there oh because like there's no way they just have to
eliminate two right there's no way i'm the last two i only
messed up the parkour like once
oh i can't see why is this so live why was the first one so
short
like okay this is bullshit shit the the first one was so
short and this feels like a the fucking level gap between
the two jesus oh all right here you please i'd rather be
average let me be the middle of the pack oh thank god
there's at least two people behind me Thank god
There's at least Because there's at least two people behind
me So we should be fine
Oh my god The fact that no one's at the safe zone yet It's
concerning me
No one's at the safe zone There's still like 200 fucking
parkour!
It never ends.
It never fucking...
It's like the marathon all over.
Like, oh my god.
Oh no.
I hope I have allies.
I...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa.
Okay.
We got conservator stamina here.
Oh god, oh god.
Oh god.
I'm going left.
It was too scary, so I'm gonna go left.
oh i hope left is okay because i only have one person i'm
following okay nice all right
okay okay i'm a little worried that there was only one
person that was there
Alright.
Oh, I'm getting better.
Wait.
Oh, God.
Someone made it.
That means there is an end.
Oh, my God.
People are making it.
That means there is an ending to this.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
No!
Checkpoint's not that bad.
okay i didn't up too much i got scared there oh god here we
go okay okay almost scared myself there okay i've refilled
that stamina oh okay but there is an ending chat
an ending.
Gives me so much hope.
Oh my god.
There is an end to this madness.
Oh, I don't like that numbers are going up.
Oh no.
I don't like that.
I don't.
Oh no.
please tell me I'm I can be middle of the pack please let me
be the middle of the pack that's all I ask oh god oh god
where is everybody oh 58 oh the numbers are increasing guys
Is that it?
Is that the end?
Oh, I'm 70 foot 1.
Let's fucking go.
Oh, I made it.
Oh, thank God.
I made it.
Oh, God.
Oh, I made it.
Oh.
Okay, I'm better than like 40 people.
Okay, we had a very scuff start.
We had an incredibly scuff start.
but we still live let's start definitely could be improved
by a lot that was oh yeah we had like a very rough time
there like that was pretty fucking rough no more no more f5
chat we've learned no more fucking f5 for us Oh, I was so
stressed out.
I was so fucking stressed out there.
My hands were literally shaking.
Oh, my God.
Now they have to eliminate five more.
Oh, God.
I just can't be the last five.
If I live, if I just can't be the last five.
I didn't mess up the parkour.
So we're okay.
Oh, my God.
My heart.
My heart can't take these games.
A goomy's behind me.
Where is she?
I don't see her.
You liars?
Oh, it's fine.
Well, I'm just happy that I was 70, so I was, like, in the
middle of the pack.
But she's right there.
Where?
I have the, I have a turn off because I took my meds today.
the voices at the moment.
Me and you'll hear her.
Guys, I don't know.
I might hear her, but I'll also hear 30 other voices.
So I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
I don't really want to hear 30 other voices.
The dark corner.
Okay.
Dark corner.
Where?
Trying to like Okay, and then I have to, like, let go W.
Okay, I'm trying to, like, remember how to, like, look at
my...
I passed it?
Oh, my God.
I can't find her.
Where is she?
Are you sure?
Are you guys...
Did you guys take your meds?
Right of the door.
Oh, this is right.
Oh, there she is!
Hello?
Who me?
Oh, no.
You want to look at me you stupid.
I could I had it muted.
I couldn't find muted.
I was right.
I took my meds I ran in front of you twice.
I took my meds.
Sorry, so I couldn't hear the voices anymore I wasn't even
talking to you.
I'm not in front of you I'm you know, I'm blind I appreciate
you, you know that You turned away from me twice.
Okay.
I don't know about that.
I don't remember that.
Oh, I muted.
I realized I was muted.
Your chat probably does Okay, yes, my chat was telling me
where you are, and I was lost.
I kept looking around.
Okay, Tucky, you're hiding in the corner.
How am I supposed to see that?
You know what?
You were running around right here.
Yeah?
You were running back and forth here.
And then you just turned away.
I was like, do you know what?
I'm done.
I don't know.
You were in the corner.
How was I supposed to know?
Tucky, what place did you get?
I got 21st.
No, I made a mistake by having F5.
And I bumped into everything.
Hi, she.
Hi.
Hey.
I was like 70 something.
So I was like in the middle of the pack.
Hey, not last.
Yeah, not last.
I was alone by myself for a while.
Wait, really?
It was scary.
That's scary.
That's spooky.
I didn't get caught by the monsters, though.
I didn't get caught either.
But I went on the right path to the monster.
Everyone went left.
So I was all alone.
Monster on the loose.
Yeah.
Yeah, that was so scary when the monsters were chasing.
the dog one was scared and went on all fours oh yeah that
guy was huge honestly i made shatter go in front of me
because i was scared there was a couple people waiting i was
just like i'm just gonna run at it wait did you wait you ran
at it how did you live uh if you have full stamina if you
just run past it usually once it aggro is you it won't be
able to chase you for long enough oh my god it's so smart
minecraft tech has like it has like an area guys why
couldn't you give me that minecraft tech like if the end end
was like over there there's so many of you why you guys
could have given me that advice that must be so like scary
like yeah yeah okay no when everyone start coming into the
game i was like oh my god i'm all alone oh my who got
eliminated we're good to see i feel like it's so
embarrassing that they put your name up at the top oh yeah
there this guy got eliminated oh no hi legalist people
getting eliminated sucks to be them right oh see that person
I could have picked them up and I didn't let's go high-fives
up top up top yeah maybe you are a bad boy I am
would you pick me up yeah if it was you I would be behind
you you have to turn You're not turning around for me?
I'll pick you up.
See, okay, wait, yeah.
I will do it.
Well, Doki, here's the problem.
I think all of us are usually ahead of you.
Yeah, yeah, but you'll turn around, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, you'll turn around, right?
Yeah, you'll turn around, right?
Girl, how are you gonna spam me on Discord?
call you on discord if you don't make it i want do not
disturb at all times you have my phone number maybe yeah i'm
gonna call you on your yeah i'll call you on your number
it's very just remember i'll call you on your phone number
to pick me up
all right i'm gonna mute again there's too many voices but
the but the gates look That's where there's three minutes
look at the timer three minutes, but the gates
Oh, whoa I wonder Oh my god, that parkour shit stressed me
out so much.
It was so my hands are shaking Oh, I just stopped sprinting
after each jump and then I had full stamina the entire time
Yeah, like I don't believe it was just so stressful.
Were you at five in the entire time?
Is that one?
No I was like, I was first person.
After I played it at 5 in the beginning, it was such a mess
because I couldn't see where I am.
So I just played first person.
I feel like this one, this next one, or the last one will
have a lot more monsters.
Because I feel like this one was parkour heavy.
Yeah, yeah, 100%.
I'm pretty sure this one is also parkour because there was
like the one with the lava in the cutscene.
We already did the lava.
No, no, the full lava though.
There was like a lot more lava though, wasn't it?
Yeah, I feel like I didn't see the other lava area, but
maybe.
How many people are you eliminating for this one?
10 in total.
So they're eliminating two each safety round.
Oh, so this one's two then.
Another two.
Yeah, so four people have been eliminated already.
Oh, so there, oh, okay, never mind.
It might be eight people.
Eight?
Guys.
Hey.
Do you automatically get up if no one picks you up or are
you stuck behind?
I think so.
So, Resing only takes a while.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we can just leave people behind then.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You leave certain people behind, but you'll pick me up,
right?
Certain people leave behind.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Certain people.
Yeah, leaving certain people behind.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But not us.
Certain people behind.
Not us.
If you don't pick me up, yeah, yeah.
I don't like you for me, but.
Gumi will be mad.
All right.
Is that true, Gumi?
Gumi, we're a package deal.
You said we're a package deal, Gumi.
What happened?
I think I understand what's going on.
I'm nodding.
Don't get betrayed by them.
I just heard something, and that's all I did here.
Don't get betrayed, bad.
Got it.
Don't betray.
Don't get betrayed.
Betray us, Bible.
Yeah, it's the one that says he's not going to raise us.
I'm not picking up certain people.
trusting don't get betrayed betrayed misheard the
overhearing no they're telling me to save them oh yeah we
should we should head over all right now i took my meds
again pure silence
it's okay oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa i see your colors
maybe i took the wrong bed
Guys, I think I took the wrong way!
We're not!
Woo!
Wait.
Where to go?
I...
I guess here?
Oh God, I can't see.
Oh God.
I'm scared.
Oh my God, where am I?
Oh my God.
Well, I hope front was the right way to go.
That's what I hope for.
I'm not using all my stamina, guys.
I'm actually learning.
oh my god who is that who is that who is that guys don't
look behind if you don't turn around and look you won't get
hurt guys i can learn i told you guys i told you guys i can
learn i figured it out guys i figured out how to conserve my
stamina if i let go all the buttons eventually i'll have
Eventually I stop, guys.
I just gotta let everything go.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Oh, God.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa.
It's okay.
There's so many people that got caught.
I didn't even see the monster.
That was the scary part.
I didn't even see the monster there.
Yay!
my stamina oh we're okay guys it only took two safe zones to
learn how to play this game god my craft is so easy a
fucking game for babies
holy shit I think somebody died in front of me I think I
think oh my god I'm pretty sure someone literally died in
front of me oh my god I was so close oh fuck that was
actually so close holy shit guys i think it's okay we're
okay watch your tone don't ever call minecraft i'm sorry
minecraft's not a game for babies i'm so sorry it's a game
for for adults it's a game for adults for 18 plus and over
but like not that type of
but not that whoa i'm 18 i did it oh my god oh i was ahead
of going oh shit
no donkey i've been standing here no i've been standing for
a long time oh my god oh my god and did it guys we fucking
did it we're so good we're so good 18 let's go oh my god
guys is this what it's like to be a fucking winner
oh my god i'm a winner Not last, let's go.
Oh my god, guys.
Oh, Warren TV.
Yeah, fuck you.
You fucked me over yesterday.
Yeah, that's right, Warren TV.
You lied to me yesterday.
That's called karma.
Oh my god.
I don't think I forgot about yesterday.
I'm a pro of Minecraft, dude.
there you go i told you karma's gonna happen karma's a bitch
oh my god i'm gonna wake up i'm gonna wake up from this
nightmare
oh my god why was this one so goddamn short compared to what
we it's like what why was this one so goddamn short
all right turning down master and bring everything down okay
we're gonna have to uh okay we're gonna have to bring down
the master volume because we have no idea what is anything
tied to what is so we're gonna bring down the master volume
we're like trying to figure out what is making the like the
ambient noises um and like what is making the ambient noises
and the monsters so we've been Korea to help.
We've been turning everything down, but it's not working.
Like, I don't understand.
Nothing was working.
Alright.
Okay, we're just gonna turn up the voice in.
We tried the weather, right?
Maybe.
It could be the weather actually.
Okay, we're gonna turn the weather down.
But is this volume too loud when we were playing?
I couldn't tell.
honestly because like uh sounding i was saying that the
monsters were being too loud so i wasn't sure
it was fine yeah it was all over yeah it is pretty all over
in the planets
yeah it was immersive true true it was immersive it was so
immersive guys see every every game we learn more about how
to play this game we learned more more about how to play.
We're getting better, chat.
We're getting better at Minecraft.
Because Minecraft is not a baby game.
That was so fucked up.
I called...
Somebody died in front of me the moment I called Minecraft a
baby game.
That was so fucked up.
I'm like, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it.
I'm like, where did the monster come from?
dude mic yeah mic mic should be an esport there should be a
bedwars esport the views will go insane yeah god struck them
for my sins god got okay look guys god's aim is a little bit
wonky guys okay he's not a game god is not a gamer guys all
right he sort of missed he fucking he just missed okay
taught me a lesson now i know never should talk minecraft no
next next game is like a puzzle it's a puzzle game so like
as long as chat you gotta help me backseat this okay guys
guys you gotta you gotta help me backseat oh my god he's
still alive
We can't believe he's still alive.
Where's Gumi?
We gotta combine our chats together.
Because if we average our chats IQs together, it'd be like
two brain cells.
And include Gumi and I.
Because like Gumi and I, we add our brains together.
It'd be like 0.1.
But if we add your chat and her chat and my chat, together.
It'd be like two.
So you guys are like 1.8.
Alright, we can do this.
We can do this.
If we put all our brains together, we can do this, guys.
There's no way.
Alright, let's see who has.
Look at all these dead bodies.
Oh my God.
Look at all these.
That's me.
I'm still alive, bitches.
I'm still alive.
I don't know how someone was feeding me But Doki we have no
brains Yep you have like 0.01% So you add it all together It
will be a 2 Guys it's a puzzle We know me in puzzles guys
All you puzzle dragoons You keep telling me to play a puzzle
game This is your time to rise up Chat Literally whenever
you guys are like Doki please play a puzzle game Play like
those like IQ games Play that IQ.
Like, was it the one where you had to draw lines or whatever
to, like, solve the puzzle?
This is your chance to rise up and backseat me.
Everybody was like, Doki, play a little to the left.
Doki, play...
Doki, play a detective game.
Doki.
This is it.
This is literally your moment to shine.
i'm too lazy to do puzzle that's okay we can do this i
believe like there's no way if like we all work we have it's
like each some people don't even have a chat to help them
guys they have to use their own brains that's why that's why
we're working together we literally have chat advantage and
like the best part is that i'm sorry to all the minecraft
theories like it's not you guys Minecraft viewers that are
watching me, this doesn't pertain to you.
This does not apply to you.
But what's the best part is that we're not Minecraft
viewers.
Our main category is not Minecraft.
So the average age of a Dragoon is at least over 13.
So we have a chance against the other Minecraft players.
so we can do it guys but like if you're a minecraft reviewer
and you're watching me this doesn't apply to you because
you're watching me so you're at your your age is already
like um gumi wait where are you gumi oh thanks gumi oh wow
it feels better ah gumi why'd you do that where's gumi am i
hearing voices again Am I?
Am I hearing voice?
Where did Gumi go?
I think the next game is the Simon Says one.
Where is she?
Did I imagine that?
You guys heard it too, right?
You guys heard it?
You guys heard that voice, right?
did you not hear what i heard guys did you not hear here
gumi oh no guys i think i'm oh gumi gumi i see you running
gumi i know you're there i know you're in front of me gumi
Gumi, where are you going?
She's losing.
Gumi?
Gumi, where are you doing?
Hey.
Gumi?
Why did you catch up so fast?
I did it.
I learned the Minecraft tech.
I was 18th place.
Are you proud of me?
I am proud.
I was ahead of you.
Yeah.
Are you proud of me?
I became the master.
I am proud.
I am Yeah, it only took me two save points Two save points
We need We need to do puzzles Yeah, yeah So your chat and my
chat can work together In solving this puzzle Yeah Right?
And Yeah, yeah, yeah Yeah, yeah Because they said emote only
isn't on Yeah, yeah, yeah Yeah, so we can backseat Oh, and
then like If our chat can look at God No, no, no.
No, I already know what you're gonna say.
I mean, people are ahead of us.
You two in this room over here?
It's a joke, guys.
Guys, if you guys didn't know, that's a joke, guys.
It's a disclaimer.
Don't do it.
It's a joke, guys.
Don't do it, guys.
We're just joking.
We're going to use our brains.
We're not going to use other people.
people's brains we're gonna use our brains together yeah
yeah and chat's brains but like with no outside help other
than that
apparently so i don't know what oh wait there's 20 easter
eggs now wait what by the way oh let me find you i was not
paying attention where are the where are the other easter
eggs look like they're tvs again oh they're more tvs yeah i
found nine of them already Doki oh here there's one right
here oh they added more TVs oh I wonder what we get for 20
eggs I got 18 I'm at 18 as well I'm at 17 what one am I
missing that you're 19 did you get the one behind the stairs
yeah I live in Buckingham Palins where's the others wait
there's one upstairs we're gonna do it again really There's
a TV's upstairs.
No, this is gonna be troll.
I did not say this.
Who said this?
There's a TV in one of the bedrooms.
I searched all six bedroom sections.
I didn't see one.
It was like hidden next to a bed.
I can't just lie.
I mean, hey, if there was one, then they found an egg.
There's no reason.
There's always a reason, chat.
There's always a reason.
joki wow joki i couldn't find one out here yeah i couldn't i
like how you knew i was lying when i talked about the
bedroom tv
well honestly i didn't even hear you but i would have known
either way i mean i just found out about the tv so yeah Oh
no, it's time!
We got work together!
He was the only one that didn't run to the bedrooms.
It's showkeeper time.
I can't believe it.
I said that and everybody ran to the fucking...
And ran to the fucking bedroom!
That's actually fucking hilarious.
That's so funny.
Oh, we've been here.
Isn't this, to be fair, this looks like the, uh, this
literally looks like the, uh, fucking first map.
Where's going?
We just ran past a familiar face.
Where did he go?
There's pictures there.
There's a lot of pictures.
Oh.
Silence.
Nice.
We did it, guys.
We're free.
Guys, I'm running out of meds, guys.
Um, I don't have ins- I don't have health insurance, guys.
I can't keep- I can't keep taking them.
We're gonna run out of bed soon.
Guys, guys, I don't want to have an addiction, guys.
Buy more.
Guys, what if I get addicted to it just like painkillers?
Guys, I don't want to be those painkiller, guys.
Oh.
Hello.
Dude, I was talking about how you actually saw me.
What?
And how rare it is.
Yeah, I saw you!
You're like a dinosaur.
You only see things that move.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
If you don't move, I don't see you.
You're like becoming a human being almost.
I see via heat vision.
I look via heat vision and like movement.
So if you don't move.
Yeah, yeah, I'm like, I'm not.
I think it's the side effects from the meds I'm taking.
Yeah, yeah.
Every time I take it, the voices disappear.
Oh, I let my voices go.
You go wild?
Right now, the voices are going...
Wait, I don't think that's healthy.
What?
I don't think that's healthy, Goom.
And then the other one's going,
Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum-Dum.
Wait, then how do you hear...
Oh, wait, how do you hear regular people?
If you're listening, hearing the voices.
It gets transcribed.
Like, there's a...
There's like a text speech.
There's a little lag.
Yeah, subtitles underneath the music.
So while you're talking, I hear, like, Nightcore in my right
ear, hamster song in my left ear.
Oh, my God.
You hear the Eurovision song, Nightcore?
Yeah, Eurovision song was...
That song is actually from Eurovision.
Yeah, I know, I know.
One, two, three, three, one, that didn't even win, right?
That didn't even win Eurovision.
Whoa!
You guys don't know Rockefeller, yeah, Rockefeller fee.
I honestly thought it was an American song.
I thought Rockefeller, Rockefeller was an American song, but
it's actually a Eurovision song.
And I don't think it even won Eurovision.
And the only reason why it's popular is because of
Nightcore.
It's only popular because of Nightcore.
I don't know.
I was thinking about Rockefeller as in the Rockefeller
Street.
You know, the Rockefeller building in New York City.
Yeah, it was Estonia.
It was from fucking Estonia.
That was like the country at least expected Rockefeller to
be from.
Because all I could think about is the Rockefeller.
building um um the rockefeller building in new york city
she was second to last in euro bishop oh my god rockefeller
was second to last to be fair that song that song is like
the most popular song during that year too i didn't know
that i thought it'd be at least popular than that like who
the fuck won eurovision during that time to be fair all
right i think everybody knows eurovision is sort of like
it's not really about the song to be very eurovision has
never really been about the song the quality of the song
it's about it's about knowing which country is
Dude, that's really it.
It's like, I'm friends with that country.
I don't care how shitty your song is, but you're my friend.
It's just like, it's just to show you guys who's friends
with who.
Oh, I'm missing strategy talks?
Oh, shit.
I was jumping around.
Wait, where's Goomy?
Music?
Fucking cringe?
Can you mute, mute, mute for me.
Okay, mute for me is not a strategy talk.
talk.
That's all I'm saying, guys.
I don't know.
Oh?
Uh-oh.
Congratulations on making it out of the basement, guys.
150 of you entered the house of nightmares and now there are
100 of you left.
The next challenge is of the conjurer's favorite nightmare
you will soon find yourself on a movie set enough what the
houses the furniture and even the cows on the farm are all
part of a fake set which the conjurer oversees personally
you will be given basic instructions this is not a puzzle
like baking cakes and brewing simple potion guys this is not
a puzzle
The curse will be cast upon the last person to successfully
finish the previous challenge.
In this challenge, your goal is to avoid being infected by
the conjure...
The puzzle bake a cake.
For the duration of the two-minute timer.
You can pass the curse to other players by tagging them.
If you are infected when the timer hits zero, belong to us
the last set of players to complete each task will be
eliminated oh god that's gonna be me guys that's gonna be me
that's gonna be me the last player will be eliminated that's
gonna be me the last player will be eliminated oh god this
is gonna be me task three the last two Goodbye, guys.
We had a good run.
It's gonna be me!
What the fuck?
Goodbye, everybody.
There's a lot of people.
What happened from like 10 to like fucking 200?
so do as the conjurer says and do it fast or your soul shall
join the house of nightmare yeah this is we had a good run
you know what we had such a good we made it this far nobody
expected me to be the last round three guys nobody expected
it wait where's my team the strategize oh
it did look like there's well did it it kind of looks like
there's teams right i'm integrating into them okay i don't
know i don't know wait yeah are they gonna divide us
randomly or do it like they did yesterday i think everyone's
on the same map i think everyone's on the same map yeah I
don't think they know I just got here.
Five eliminations on the curse, so we just need all to be
together.
And like, honestly, when they finish a task, I would get
away from it and go hide somewhere in the game.
Yes.
Once you do it, it kind of goes task by task, right?
You do the task and then someone gets eliminated.
You do it, then we run.
If it is separate groups, I don't think it would be.
I think that's too many people.
It was like one, one, two, three, four, four, only eliminate
20 people.
That's way too many to be split up because it's like 15 per
group.
at that point well one and i think it's going to be one in
five for each group gets eliminated so if they do five teams
how do i make a cake in minecraft guys how do i make a cake
in minecraft i mean that's why i think they're gonna do
batches of uh teams right how do i do it for potions all you
do is you do nether wart and then you do whatever i think
the recipe will be there because there's no way they're
gonna there's you guys how do i make make potions because
i've never made a potion before yeah i was right so whoever
gets like the slowest gets eliminated and then like the next
valid person that would be like last to finish is going to
get the curse so you just get out as soon as you make you
make your teams and then you compete against your team again
i don't know i don't think i don't think is everybody in the
same map is everyone on the same map it's 100 everyone on
the same year old guys rise up yeah yeah yeah we need you we
need you Let me make a cake in the ocean.
It is a lot.
That's really overwhelming.
That's so long.
Now's the time to take a shot to like eliminate, just about
go grab the curse and then.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I thought you were going to say like take a shot, like
alcohol and I'm like, I'll bet.
Oh, no, no, no.
No, no.
How do you make a cake in Minecraft?
Is it better to be with friends or not with friends?
What do you think?
If I somehow get the curse, can you let me tag you so I can
chase someone?
In theory, none of us should be cursed.
So me, can I tag you so you can tag him?
No.
What?
happened to her package deal wait so does everybody play hot
potato or just yes yes to him there'll be one person out of
a hundred so you just got to be lucky at that point like you
just got to get away from the last people it seems like i
don't know if there's a delay i'm passing it i think it's
not a delay so you could also just go to the end and punch a
person a sweat won't have the potato and if they do
something terribly wrong happens so yeah they're gonna wait
till last second and punch someone entrance i mean are we
gonna is it is this the entrance oh two minutes two minutes
i'm scared guys we at the bottom one egg with two sugar on
each side for the milk and three guys okay the moment we get
the cake i need you guys to spam that okay so so when you
have the stuff for the All right, good luck, guys.
Okay, so you open your inventory and you see where like your
shield would go, like your all-pand.
So slightly to the right of that, you click.
And does it open your crafting menu?
Yeah?
We have a crafting menu?
Just start clicking right away.
You'll find it.
Yeah, click like a little bit to the right of where your
all-pand is in your inventory.
How do I- How do we open our inventory?
You see at the top left there's like a red X next to the
thing on the right?
Oh my god!
You want to click that and so it says showing craftable with
the check mark.
And then once you get the stuff for a cake, it'll tell you
how to...
Like, it'll, like, literally just...
You just click on it and it'll make it for you.
Yeah, then you can just click it.
We gotta go.
Guys, we need to walk over there.
Wait, what did he teach them?
I forgot!
I had put Minecraft in for so long!
I can't even forget!
It's been just so long!
We didn't know!
Where are you?
I don't know, but people got eliminated.
A Minecraft player got eliminated.
Thursday.
You gotta follow my voice, Fulham?
No, no, I wanna hear a louder, louder, louder.
Hello, Fulham.
Right click on the shield?
There's nothing on the shield.
Stop meowing, you fervious.
Stop it.
Oh.
Oh, God.
Where are my tasks?
Find fuel at the fuel power the generator.
Um.
I hope these guys are heading to the generator.
Wait, did I near the farmer's house?
Oh.
Okay, I got confused.
I got confused.
Everybody was clicking.
Oh, Erop didn't bring the...
I
don't run.
Oh, I run.
Fused.
Everything was so confusing.
Oh my god.
We gotta run.
We gotta hide.
Run.
Oh my god.
People are trying to camouflage.
I like how people are trying to camouflage right now.
Oh my god, there's still like three people that have it What
the fuck The fuck is that Okay Alright How is there still
like three people That haven't done There's still like three
people that haven't done the thing Yeah I like this spot
Yeah There's no way they can't parkour this.
Oh wait, hold on.
Up there.
Ooh.
Yeah, wait a minute.
Hold on.
Yo, yeah.
Shift back here for the tag section.
Hold on.
Look up, look up, look up, look up.
They won't find us really, shouldn't they?
Wait.
We're fine, we're fine, guys.
Oh wait.
We're fine.
No, no, I wanted to.
It's a bit of alarming that Feinberg and Fairfire left.
Oh, who is it?
Oh, someone's got eliminated.
Hang tight until the next one begins.
I know what.
guys this is such a good hiding spot good job oh i see them
over there oh whoa whoa what the fuck oh what oh god where
are we running they're over there isn't that behind us run
okay there's i don't know where she is i'm scared i'm so
scared i don't know where they are i hope he died Is he
behind me?
Are they behind me?
I can't tell.
I'm so scared.
I'm just gonna keep running because I don't know.
There's no upstairs?
No, no way I'm here.
Wait, can we see the motherfuckers through walls?
Wait,
do we see them?
Where are they?
Are they out there?
They can.
Do the motherfuckers wear COVID faster than us?
just just be it no no no i'm correct oh well yeah you're
awesome i i am very much correct
everybody's in the house they're all in the house come in
the house are we online curry what are you doing bro here
guapo come come come come i hope so are they aren't they
glowing purple or something something like that i think we
can see the rules like an outline or what They're pretty
fine.
Why don't we see it?
False, come up here.
I hear a heartbeat or does everybody hear that?
Yeah, it's getting like lost though.
Ah, there's ladders.
I'm scared.
Guys.
How?
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Thank God I speak Spanish.
Come, come, come, come.
The shell, the shell.
Hide, hide, hide.
Ship, ship, ship.
Map door.
Two seconds.
Let's go.
That was not the...
Okay.
Wolfie.
Oh my gosh.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Collect water from the crate near the water well.
Collect the water well.
Where's the water well?
Oh yeah, where is the water well?
I don't know.
Where's the water well?
Where's the water well, Reggie?
Oh no.
Oh wait, that's the well right there.
Inside the house, inside of the fridge.
Inside the fridge.
I don't trust you, man.
In the farm, in the farm, in the farm.
I'm gonna keep it above 50.
I do not trust you.
Where's the sugar in the house, guys?
Go get it.
I'm sick.
Uh, collect sugar.
Oh, this is the water.
Where is it?
I'm so scared.
Is that sugar cane over there?
Oh my god, please tell me that it is.
What if the sugar is coming from like a...
Please tell me that it is.
I'm just following the crowd!
Where's the bottle?
Oh, I got it.
You can just grab it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where's the netherward for him?
Where's the netherward?
I see, I see another word.
Yeah, where's the netherward?
Where's the netherward?
Oh yeah, that's this way.
Where are we going?
How do we get it?
The netherward's this way?
It's by the fuel power.
Oh, it's over there.
How do I grab the sugar?
Don't go in here.
Oh, the netherward, follow the crown!
You guys, where's netherward?
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
Where's the house?
Go to the house.
Where did you guys get the water?
Oh, I'm so screwed.
the water please wait where's the water from the cabinet i'm
just gonna follow i'm just gonna follow i'm just gonna
follow i'm gonna follow i'm gonna follow yeah i'm gonna
follow are you going to the powder i believe yes i am going
to the powder okay okay i follow you leads to the middle of
it i don't know where the water is where's the water oh
where's clutch he doesn't have water yeah where's the
cabinet over here Oh
Wait was that a chicken coop over there?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure the Are you going to brood the chicken
coop?
Where's the chicken coop?
Where's the chicken now?
Where's the chickens are?
Yeah, I think it's in the house, right?
It's in the house?
Where's the chicken coop?
Where's the water?
I don't know where the chicken coop is.
I don't know how to get the water.
Where's the chicken coop?
Guys, where's the chicken coop?
Is that it?
That's the chicken coop.
That's where everybody is.
That's where all the chickens are!
Sugar first.
No, no, no.
How do I ruin it?
Sugar first.
No, it's an awesome post, man.
Really?
Yeah.
Where's the conjurer's first test?
What is it?
What the fuck is the conjurer?
What's the top left?
And then what?
And then I put sugar?
What happens off to the sweet punch?
Where's that?
Okay.
And then I'll put sugar?
What do I get?
Get her wine, Captain!
Holy!
But, but...
No, no, no, no, Shadow and Shadow Yeah, it's only for the
leatherware.
Oh, there is a card here.
Okay, so we need to get another bottle of water, Flex, no?
No, no, no, I have the speed, I have the speed, I have the
speed.
oh god where's the counter false is the big guy so big guy
to the left big guy to the left thank you thank you okay hi
big guy so we got we in the very middle yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah i lived ideal oh my god it was so so stressful okay
it's like we were back over there there's the house it's
fine so we were getting that There's a word someone was
getting water, so we're fine.
Wait, where's milk?
Do we have something to milk in the air today?
It's fine as a guide.
Oh, that was so stressful.
There's going to be cake next to.
I see a cow right there.
Yeah, the cow right there.
There's another word of milk there.
I'm scared.
Guys, I feel like I'm going to die from the curse.
I think I'm going to die from the curse.
Yeah.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
over there and then sugar over there yeah eggs over there
sugar there where's the cow it's in the farm oh oh i see it
yeah maybe we shouldn't stand right next to him while
everyone's getting their stuff no well i feel like we don't
necessarily know which one we should we should use this time
to take yeah yeah yeah this is where everything is every mob
that's around is there for a reason so i kind of want to
just take them like what is that right there your objective
you see that like there's a cow over there water's like a
sheep or no that's a she looks like look like a sheep yeah
where's the wheat how do we get into the wheat there's a
door over there looks like a sheep door inside the house
yeah yeah let's look at the entrances
this one this one over here looks like it's gonna be an
archery test yes yeah i think I don't know how to do archery
in Minecraft.
Just imagine triple take.
There's a bullet drop off.
Follow, follow, follow.
Bro, are you just falling?
I'm high rolling by the, I'm high rolling standing by the
chest over there.
This is the cow.
We got to get the wheat.
Wait, that's not a real cow.
It's a human.
I feel like you just want to, I just want to know where it
is, though.
Like, I want to know.
Look at his face.
That's not a real cow.
That can't be a cow.
Yeah, but he could be like a costume.
to wait you can get on the walls just wait these are all
freaks there's no way there's like a head there's no way
that's a cow it looks like a human cow it looks like some
homocular shit wait is a sheep also like that hey don't
judge what the fuck they all have those eyes those creepy
eyes the man cow bear they all have those eyes so what the
fuck is wrong with her she what is they all look like they
have ptsd they all have they all look like they have ptsd or
some shit oh insane what little cheats you got a parkour
legend here how do we even get up there
oh my god like they just look like they are traumatized
about something they like they've seen things see yeah yeah
we just don't put sugar first
oh my god i feel like some people got over because they put
sugar first
holy god i'm nervous being alive i don't know i don't know
if it's good to be like like to live past this right now for
the objective because like I'm getting more stressed the
more the more task we get I'm getting more stressed out if I
was eliminated I could be chilling right now holy shit I'm
so like I'm actually so scared that's okay We're going to be
transported when the curse starts.
When the curse starts, we're going to be transported so it
doesn't matter.
You'll get mid.
Get out of the fields.
I'm out.
Oh, there's, like, cows here, too.
We're going to have to find the bucket.
You know damn well that 70k is going to a fucking
minecrafter.
Guys, you know that, chat.
There's no way a regular person is going to get that 70k.
Minecrafters have been playing Minecraft games for years.
It's been 20.
It's been almost 20 years since Minecraft came out.
Some of these Minecraft streamers have been streaming
Minecraft since, like, it came out, guys.
Loser talk.
Yeah, sureport, why aren't you in here?
That was 70k.
That could have been an easy 70k for you, sureport.
Why aren't you here?
and 50 people guys oof that's an oof right there sure for i
can't believe it they asked sk and they didn't ask you
sleepy and warren were it sleepy warren and mendo were here
man is it like no it's individual it's like an individual
ship it's okay sleepy warren all the overwatch players got
eliminated by the way though oh yeah Every Overwatch player
that got in, got eliminated, man.
You could have been the one that lived.
You could have been the last remaining Overwatch player.
Oh, no.
How awful.
That could have been you.
Oh, yeah, we should.
We should be in the middle.
Oh, yeah, we gotta be in the middle.
Because we're gonna teleport us soon.
I forgot about that.
That's why you guys want me to be out of the field.
my dog alone oh my god EROB was 96 yeah I need yeah I forgot
I need to be all the way over there oh this is scary please
please 97 give me a give me a sec to join the the crowd let
me guys I'm lost no oh no I'm fucked oh no I'm fucked myself
over I'm not with the crowd guys i don't know how to get out
of here
oh no oh no guys oh there's the crowd there's the crowd oh
he's not oh god go see behind us i see him i see him i'm
going this way i'm in this way i see them i'm seeing them i
see them going this way.
I fell on these guys.
It's so over.
I didn't know where I was.
Don't shift.
Punch.
Don't stick up.
Just punch.
Just punch in front so we don't stick up.
All right.
Can we still see them glowing?
This is an insane spot, bro.
It's gonna be so busted next time.
Get that chicken head out of there.
Move your heads.
Oh, it's coming!
I'm joking.
Why do you guys think this is fun?
I'm saying that.
Guys, I heard shift and I was like, oh, shift.
And they're like, don't shift.
I was like, shift.
Don't move.
No, no, no.
It's coming, it's coming.
Don't move.
Go, go, go.
Don't worry.
The Spanish Minecrafters know what they're doing.
The Spanish Minecrafters know what they're doing!
Of course they do!
Minecraft is very popular over there!
Look at Quaggity!
Freddy, come with us, Freddy.
The fucking head!
Freddy!
Freddy, prosper!
Oh, it's behind you!
Oh, he's right behind me, is he?
Nice!
Did it!
Oh, we did it!
Oh, good.
Find a note at the farmer's house.
Where is the farm?
Gumi!
I'm right behind you!
Gumi's not slowing down, guys!
Gumi!
Because Gumi's not slowing down for me!
I got that.
Wrong house!
Dude, I got so bot spawned!
That was such a bot spawn.
Go to the fuel tower.
Wait, is it the right house?
Fuel tower, they said fuel tower.
Is that not the right house?
Yeah, that they're trolling.
Wait, who's the right house?
Yeah, they were just... Oh.
Oh, donkey run!
I'm running!
I didn't know!
They were trolling!
I trusted You!
Is he in the house?
Oh my god.
We were just at the bottom.
That's so good.
Wait, where is it?
Comey, where?
I don't know, desk?
Desk?
Over here?
Wait, where's the desk?
Right here!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
I got it!
Oh my god!
We got trolls!
so high, Gumi!
Oh, this is bad.
We got trolled.
Alright, back to it.
I've seen the chest.
I'm just gonna follow Gumi.
Oh, no.
We saw it, too.
Oh, my God.
This is so nerve-wracking.
Literally one guy.
I got so confused.
That's so fucked up.
It's so fucked up.
Where's the chest?
It's up.
I follow Gumi.
I got confused!
Never follow Gumi!
use
a note to find a chest try 19.93 oh is it the number on your
file one one nine three wait I'm not in it?
where do I take it?
find the note right here right there 1993 the code is 1993
click on it 1993 the books are at the top of the barn okay?
the books are at the top of the barn the chest is behind the
barn God, oh, I got panicked guys.
I panicked I panicked everybody I couldn't read because I
was panicking Did you get the note?
Did you get the note?
Run, run, run Run.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, find a new new new pile of books.
Oh my god.
Where's the note?
Go up, go up, go up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah Up here.
I don't know where to go That's my name books right here We
have to fight right now Oh
I'm so stressed out I'm so stressed out Holy I'm so stressed
out Oh my god!
Use your note.
I'm clicking it with the note.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna practice.
Yo, you guys want to do archery practice right now?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna practice, guys.
Oh god, there's fall off.
Which one's my arrow?
So if it's just one of them.
Okay.
We got aim high.
Don't even know which one's mine.
Yeah, I'm just gonna go to the middle.
I'm gonna, there's no point in winning.
Oh, it's for practice.
I see.
I wish I was better with the bow.
What are we gonna use?
Goomi went the wrong way several times.
I couldn't trust her anymore.
I couldn't trust her.
She went the wrong way in several times.
Sonic got 11.
I'm sorry.
Fox got eliminated.
Yeah, look, look, you're good.
Yeah.
One in each side.
Oh, chickens.
Fuck.
Fuck, deal.
Going this way.
I'm going to the house.
I don't know.
I'm scared.
I'm going to the house.
They are coming this way.
Oh, my God.
Which way are they coming over?
I'm so scared.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Guys, goodbye, everybody.
Goodbye, everyone.
This might be where we die.
it might be where you where we die no okay oh no oh fucking
no oh no guys this is it we actually got hit
oh no yes this is it guys it was so nice playing with you
guys we're gonna get eliminated Father Chris To the gate to
the gate to the gate to the gate to the gate What am I gonna
make it We're gonna make it to the gate We might make it We
might make it to the gate We might make it to the gate.
We might make it to the gate.
I knew the gate.
I was there.
I was there at the gate I was the gay person!
Stay here, stay here, stay here.
Look at my mind.
Oh.
Run, run, run.
Dude, they tried to talk me.
They tried to get me out of this stuff, bro.
They tried to talk to me.
Oh, God.
The arm?
I knew it's gonna stag with the arm.
I knew it.
I'm behind.
I'm behind the gate.
The gate.
Bro,
you actually need, you all need to get out of my way.
I swear to God, I'm a freak out.
Is somebody gonna match my freak?
Oh my god, please give me one.
Give me one at least.
Oh my god, how many did I get?
It's pretty fire already.
Oh my god.
It's a one shot.
It's a lot of fun.
Oh my god.
Okay,
Okay, there's a bunch outside the barn.
Red, there's a ton outside.
Oh my god.
Yeah, right here.
Okay, good.
Oh my god, I need one more.
I need one more too!
Oh god.
This way is faster.
You can jump up from the stairs.
You can stand here and jump from here.
Oh no, no, no.
Where's the conjure?
In the middle?
Okay.
How do we get there?
How do you guys get there?
Oh no.
It's probably the, it's either the cake or the target
practice.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Give me an even, give me an even up there.
So stressful.
I hate this game.
Oh my God.
Oh,
please.
Guys, I'm going to be the last 10.
There's no fucking way.
Look it.
Oh.
This is too much.
My heart.
My fucking heart, man.
My fucking heart.
I can't.
My hands are shaking and I'm so stressed out and I want this
to be over.
Oh boy.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, I'm just gonna go here.
My heart can't take it.
My heart.
My heart can't take it, guys.
So how many challenges are left, too?
I'm assuming there's two more challenges and then one more
curse round, probably.
How many have we done so far?
Okay.
We've done four curse rounds.
Someone could hit this double now.
They're never getting tagged.
No, I don't think you can, because the...
Wait, I got it, I got it.
Wait, that's just so much better, isn't it?
Jesus Christ, I got infected as the first person, but...
He didn't notice, I infected him back, so we're saying...
Oh my god, dude.
I'm like hungry too.
I can't.
I'm so dead people.
We're here, we're here!
I don't know
Wait, is that one there's one more one more time?
Hang in there, Toki.
Uh-oh, they're getting chased.
They're getting chased.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh, stinky.
You're not just gonna hide here.
Aren't you gonna dip?
Yeah, it's...
Okay, if they ran in through stairs, we need to just escape.
nervous yeah i'm taking i'm taking the root out of the back
if they get all these guys stinky the best point yeah yeah
surely internal panic oh god jump down there to fight them
yay we lived just to get eliminated we lived to get
eliminated It's water time.
Oh my god, of course it's bucket, bro.
It's water time.
You think the water well has the bucket?
Okay, we didn't go the wrong way, so that's good.
Cow pen, where's the cow pen?
There.
Cow pen's at the cow pen.
At the cow pen.
Where's the cow pen?
Where the fuck is the cow pen?
It's over here.
Brown cow.
Follow the Spanish Minecrafters.
The cows look a little silly.
Okay, I think we don't know where we're going.
Okay.
Follow the Spanish mine crafters!
They know what they're doing!
It's a kick time?
It's kick time, guys.
Get the recipe ready, guys!
Get the recipe ready!
Guys, how do I get to that weed faster?
You're not near it.
Where's the well?
The well?
The well is by the barn.
It's in front of the barn.
Oh no!
Guys, I don't know how to get to the way!
Why would they be in the front?
Guys, GG's guys.
It was...
Where's the cow?
It was a good run.
We're like man, everyone else is dumb except for us.
It was a good run I don't know how to get to that weed.
I'm so I'm gonna go here Guys, GG.
It was a good run.
I don't know how to get to that weed faster.
It was a good run Goodbye Goodbye everybody.
I'm too stressed out to do jumps
collect an egg oh i know how to get the egg this way this
way oh
no guys jesus i don't know the route oh no i forgot the egg
route guys i forgot how guys where's the eggs yeah it has to
be next right but next one's awesome guys where's the eggs
is this the chicken coop no where's the eggs where's the
eggs check where's the eggs farmer house is it this way oh
guys I didn't know where the eggs were.
I didn't know where the eggs were, guys.
Is this where the eggs are?
Guys.
I didn't know where the eggs are.
Chee-chees.
Guys, you know where the eggs?
I'm confused.
Where are the eggs?
Nobody's helping!
Guys, it was a good run.
she don't know where the eggs are guys you guys know where
the eggs are guys do you guys know where the eggs are yeah
it's at the farmer's house where's the farmer's house again
i think i'm out though i'm i'm fucking gts do you know where
the farmer's eggs are good to me you know where the eggs i'm
i think i think it's over i got lost some eggs i got lost
some eggs i survived the second day My chat fucked me.
My chat made me lost.
And me too.
I'm lost too.
We were both lost.
Right click, right click, hurry, right click, hurry and run
out.
Okay.
We got the eggs.
We both got... Chat is you and I.
We both got lost together!
Yeah.
Come on, hurry, hurry, hurry, hurry.
Oh, I'm hurry, I'm hurrying, I'm hurrying.
I'm so lost.
It was a good run, Gumi.
Gumi.
You live on for me, Gumi.
Gumi, live on for me.
It's too late.
It's too late, Gumi.
We had a good run.
You and we just live.
Gumi.
Gumi, it's okay.
It's over.
Gumi, you have to accept the fact that it's over.
It's over, Gumi!
Gumi, it's over!
It's over!
At last!
All right, I'm here to curse you all now.
I'm the curse.
Oh my god.
It's time All right, it's time to be the curse Oh my god
Holy shit Chad we're both idiots.
We're both fucking idiots Oh my god Oh, never mind Shane i
was banking on following you this round oh my god you seem
very you seem very indecisive which is kind of concerning me
whom he actually clutched it well now you're going to my
spot whom he actually clutched it what no no no trust trust
trust person knows though so they're coming they're coming
they went the other way at the start so i don't know if
they're gonna You know, he clutched her through the ram with
the chest.
Everyone's running.
Josh, how do we get out of this place?
Yo, yo, yo, yo.
Speed's over, what are you doing, bro?
Bro, they can see you.
Bro, you have to glitch up.
That's the only way.
Where's Sylvie?
Hello?
Hi, Apple.
I think people discovered our spot.
Coming,
coming!
Coming!
Coming, coming!
I'm coming!
I'm coming, I'm coming!
Run, run here, run here.
I don't think they're coming.
I don't think so.
Put the chair under the table.
It's good.
I was kidding.
Guys, bullet.
Save, save, save, save.
Try to get momentum.
Come in, come in, come in.
You're right behind me.
You're right behind me, isn't he?
Shout out to Gumi.
Gumi, shout out to Gumi for taking me all the way to the
end.
So how are y'all doing?
They come here when you took Andre's and go.
Yeah, I told him.
What the?
I'm trying to get him bullied.
Guys, we're both idiots, guys.
There were so many instructions that I got scared.
You know I panicked, guys.
You know I panicked.
We were both at fault.
That's all.
Except the fact that we both got together.
Wait, Tombo got to see him.
Oh, no.
Okay, now this is where we leave.
I got Kadazer theme.
How is someone already finished?
You're bugging my shots, bro.
Give me a little space here, man.
I don't know.
I got a 12th, man.
I got a choke.
Locked in a still.
No, we're here.
We should hide our back in the locker with somebody.
Locked in.
Oh, he's so blue.
I can't hit it.
You can do it.
What?
That's it?
Oh.
You can do it.
Remember, bullet drop off.
Bullet drop off.
Aim a little higher.
Nice, Sophie.
Oh, I got it!
I got it!
Yes!
One more!
Wait!
You got it, darling!
I have to do another day of this!
I'm just waiting again.
Cumi.
Wait.
We have to do this.
Oh my god.
Three, Gumi, wait, wait.
You mean it?
We have to take three, Gumi.
You did it, let's go.
It was the very last person.
I was, Gumi, I was 85, and then I tagged somebody instantly.
I know, I saw it.
Oh my god.
Gumi, you did it.
Me and my chat.
Now we play Valorant after this.
Okay, Gumi, my heart cannot take it right now.
I'm fucking...
I just want you to know, I went through like the five stages
of grief there.
Oh my god, no, my anxiety was peaking for you.
Not even for myself, like the entire game, I didn't feel
super anxious until you had...
I was so lost.
I didn't know where the eggs were.
I was begging.
My crafters were so cruel.
Nobody would tell me where the eggs are.
And then they sometimes they lie.
Sometimes they tell you and then I'm like, wait, I don't
believe you.
I'm like, wait, maybe I don't believe that.
You're not allowed to swear, but they gaslight us instead.
They gaslight us.
But hey, but we made it.
We made it.
We did it.
Is it going to be something scary?
Is something scary going to happen?
And then there's a possibility that we don't make it
because...
Guys, I don't know where the forum is or the hotel is.
There's so many houses.
No, the hard part was you guys were like stop back there
forward.
That was what fucked me up
Wait, you guys are like back forward and I was like back
forward front flat
Oh my god Wait, I was on the main stream.
Oh my god Well, I said my truth.
I said my truth, guys.
My truth, I didn't study.
Please.
A barn can be a house.
I don't know.
I've never been on the farm before.
I'm a city gal.
I don't know what's what.
you don't say oh my god 40 people get 40 40 elims tomorrow
yeah tomorrow that's hard no i don't i still need two more a
house is a house tubo died for this yeah minecrafter died so
i can live on to day three right i don't know in my heart if
i get a five stack it's a five stack a five stack Okay, if
you get a fast sack going.
But I'm going to go grab food, though.
I haven't finished my food.
The last B-Tuber lives on.
I can't believe it.
A minecrafter died so I can be in day three.
I took an actual minecrafter spot.
Hi.
Where are the new Easter eggs?
Oh.
Equivalent exchange.
I'm just happy it's over.
I'm happy.
I can't believe it.
Oh!
I can't believe.
Tomorrow we go again.
Oh my god.
Two more days.
Oh.
made it like four times I should not be alive I should not
feel I already was going through like the five stages of
grief of getting eliminated like I have the plot armor I'm
the main character the main character plot guys guys how
about we both fucked up together during that the egg part
the egg section we both messed up okay as a group we both
take responsibility and then goomy clutched it for
goomy clutched it for us but we both messed up together
oh my god okay group picture um oh gosh oh give me celebrate
anything he's gone wait who's guy everyone's gone
everybody's gone yeah i took last cup van i was the last
person i took a minecrafter's place that's i don't even play
this game i just learned he is inventory today that's
That's amazing.
Oh my gosh.
What horrifying thing to hear.
Yay.
Are we looking at the same area?
I don't know.
Where am I supposed to look at?
I hope I'm looking at the whoa I hope I'm looking at the
right area I don't know who's the cameraman who's the
cameraman two minutes oh okay you know I have to be in front
for exposure as the as the one of the last few non minecraft
players in this lobby.
I deserve to be in the front.
Who lets them be?
That's not fair.
You guys have to be mature about this.
I was mature enough to take responsibility.
But now you guys also have to be mature enough to also take
responsibility.
Guys, we are mature adults here.
We should both equally take the blame.
guys we both equally shared the blame but we can all agree
gloomy clutched it for us gloomy saved our asses who was it
i kept on going left right back for me
We did it.
No.
It was me!
Guys, look.
I was very overwhelmed.
I see.
I see not Minecraft.
I am already directionally challenged, guys.
I was already very directionally challenged.
Oh, you finally relaxed.
Why does...
Guys.
Why did my urge...
of wanting to win overpowered my rest week.
I can't believe we made it to taste good.
It doesn't matter.
We're gonna get eliminated anyway.
Oh, we're just too competitive.
Oh my God.
This is the most stressful rest week of all time.
It really is.
really it's it's actually the most stressful rest the week
we've had i each game has it's like i there's why am i so
stressed out why am i so stressed out
oh my god oh my god yes all right we're gonna call it here
we might apparently gloomy wants to file a stack back after
i finish eating and uh uh after we finish eating and um give
um i get uh wait what was i gonna say fuck oh sorry after i
finish eating we might pop up on goomy stream um and so i'm
gonna give her a raid hey guys for this we're new here i
actually stream on the youtube's is less stressful over
there um it's it's a lot less stressful over on the YouTube
side.
So check me out there.
If you don't want anxiety each game, because I don't know
how to read, check me out on the YouTube.
And if you guys want to know whenever I go live on Twitch,
check me out, like follow me on Twitter.
So you know whenever I'm live on Twitch, guys.
And, well, if you want to support me through your other
Ames, please feel free to check out my merch.
Hey, guys.
I can finally stop shaking I swear nothing has made me as
anxious or stressed out lately but this like I don't even
play Minecraft I don't know why I don't even play Minecraft
why is this so fucking nerve-wracking hey guys as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check grab them around to
get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed
because you deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys Oh,
yeah.
Forgot to say thank you for all the subs, bids, and fiosks.
Sorry, I've been so stressed out that I've been so
forgetful.
So, bonus ending.
Thank you for all the subs, bitties, and fios, everybody.
Anyway, bye for real.